الى احدى محطات المترو الباريسيه وصل ضابط
عراقي بحقيبه فيها ملايين الدولارات
التقى باحد مساعدي جاك شيراك وسلمه المال
لتمويل حملته الانتخابيه
مشهد من التاريخ يعود لثمانينيات القرن
الماضي كشف عنه سالم الجميلي مدير شعبه
امريكا في مخابرات حزب البعث العراقي في
حوار مع صحيفه الشرق الاوسط
الاموال تروح كاش
وكانت تسلم في في مترو
العريس ضابط مع الحقيبه
المبعوث اللي جاي من طرف وعشيرات متفقين
على
شفره معينه ويسلم الحقيبه وهذا تكرر اكثر
من مره
ما كشفه الجميلي سبق وان تحدث عنه الرئيس
السابق لجهاز الاستخبارات البريطانيه
السير ريتشاردير لوف ان الرئيس الاسبق
لفرنسا تلقى اموالا من صدام حسين لتمويل
حملاته الانتخابيه في عام
1995 وعام 2002 وهو ما جعل شيراك يعارض
غزو العراق
ومن فرنسا الى باكستان وصولا الى ليبيا
ولبنان حيث مول النظام العراقي السابق
بالمال والسلاح
بخرت
المعركه كبد الحقيقه
خسائر كبيره
يعني ممكن
سوري
قتلوا في تلك الفتره يعني هذا سوريا كثير
تهددت الحقيقه
وظل يعني مش العام في مركز قوه رحل صدام
حسين لكن اسراره باقيه كشف منها القليل
والكثير مازال طي الكتمان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات